your mere beauty miss moira
brings me to my knees
i'm just kidding i'm just kidding
not yet not yet not yet okay first of
all
moira i got bangs because of you
i love them i got moira bangs
how are you guys feeling the journey is
over
it is over but it has just begun but
it's just begun
calvin once you get to the outside are
you ever gonna eat an oyster again that
was one of the best things i've ever
watched
oh my goodness i will probably never eat
another oyster again
i don't want to jinx it uh it is an
aphrodisiac
but let me tell you i was not aroused
eating that oyster
i just wasn't for me that was that was
interesting you know it was one of those
things i'm not a huge secret person
but we we made it through another
obstacle
along our journey oh my god that was so
funny when you that oyster and
afterwards i was like did you like do
you like them he's
like yeah it's just the first time
trying it you two
you know calvin was the one that turned
moira's head after
away from james all the way back in the
beginning um but you both kind of had
your
heads on swivels like the whole time why
do you think it was so hard to just kind
of
give yourselves to each other you know
the last time we came around calvin and
i got coupled back
up and is when i really um
i really felt at home there it was like
that last week and a half that like the
whole experience
made it all work absolutely i think for
me personally
um moira was the first girl that i took
on a date and really got to know in the
villa first connection there
and there was something that i couldn't
put my finger on
that was just not um in alignment
and for a while um i thought that it was
something to do and our time apart
really allowed me to see that there were
things that i needed to work on
and then it wasn't moira's
responsibility or any other person's
responsibility
to you know bring out my best self or
put
these things out in the open but it was
on me and so once i learned that and
figured that out
once we got back together and and
connected back up it was just
light years ahead so i'm uh i wouldn't
change a thing which is kind of crazy to
say
we talked about this a lot but because
of the journey that we've had in the
time that we have spent apart it really
has brought us close together
so how do you guys hope that you were
perceived by
viewers because i know you kind of don't
know yet you don't have your phones back
yeah i mean uh
i feel like most people would just want
for people to see who they truly
are and you know respect that whether
it's
agreeing with what they've like put out
there or not
and i really hope that i just get that
you know
sort of feedback from people and is that
i'm um but
whether they agree with my decisions or
not or
however they feel about me like it will
it's
not going to be hate or you know
anything nasty
i totally yeah i totally agree i think
that
coming into the villa in this whole
experience i really wanted to
um just be myself and have a real
experience
in a almost
crazy setting if that makes sense like
the villa is not a normal it's very
out out there experience but to bring
that realness
and so uh personally i feel like every
situation
every conversation and every connection
that i did
experience was a very real connection
and it was a real process for me i've
experienced stuff like that outside the
villa
and we're talking about it's easy to
want to
grab onto a connection really quick and
hopefully you know that works out and
then you just kind of like fray the
storm
and that's really not the way we took it
we
experienced it the way we would in the
real world which is you know coming
coming full circle back together and
really making things work and so
yeah hopefully people can see that i'm
uh pretty
down to earth but but do like to have
fun
yeah i i was told by a few people that i
need to see your body roll
and i don't know what that means calvin
is that where you told that is that is
that going for right now i mean
yes yes he has the best body roll
let me just let me give y'all a little
out of all the body rolls
i thought you did that's all you get
that was hey wait wait i'm slacking you
got to do it again
oh again
[Laughter]
i love it moira the coupling with with
connor was super interesting
in the way that everything unfolded
because mackenzie like
felt betrayed by it and then she was
like one of your best friends and then
conor also told me that he felt like he
maybe led you on in a little
a little bit so how did you feel getting
caught up
just between these two
oh my gosh
hi mckenzie hi connor um
they are i love them um it was a really
interesting dynamic
to be put in that situation um and to
try and
like get through it um i
i had known that a lot of the girls in
the villa had to
just you know pick different guys at
different points
and we all were friends so i was under
under the impression that
it'd be okay if i you know had conor as
a partner
because like i said other it's part of
the experience
and then to find out that she wouldn't
be okay with that
was it was uh hard to hear but she did
say she had like no hard feelings so
that was good but i was still
a little bit um yeah that
that hurt i think the relationship the
friendship
a little bit and then um to be partnered
with connor that was
i love connor to death but me too by the
way
yes yes but that was um that was
interesting because
i you know he uh he definitely wanted to
keep it just
friendship he mentioned that he was
trying to make it more than friends
but um that he couldn't get there and
you know this is life like i totally
understand you can't force anyone to try
and
become more than friends so i just had
to like
pick my feet up uh excuse me pick them
up and just keep moving on um but like i
said he's
he's one of my best friends he's he's
honestly the easiest person one of the
easiest people to talk to in the villa
as well
yeah well at the end uh when conor left
you were like go get mackenzie like
rooting them on
now they are together like physically
together
um really that's crazy
[Music]
gus has his daddy back so
you guys finally found your way back to
each other and
it seemed like you guys were friends for
a little bit that made out sometimes but
then towards the end
i was like oh this is like getting
relationshipy so where
are things gonna go from here do you
have a plan
yeah absolutely so it was interesting
coming out of
the whole cosmo experience and finding
each other again
growing up hard going back together and
establishing
our friendship which i think was
definitely crucial
in where we're at right now and building
off of that connection
and so ever since we uh i came into the
villa
i remember having the first conversation
with moira and she was coupled up not
with me
at the time um and she said she wanted
to take things day by day
and that was that was fun with me i was
uh 100
there and our whole time in the villa
it's really been daylight day because
things change so drastically at every
hour
every minute every conversation and
it's worked out really well so far and
so moving forward outside
of the villa outside of love island and
into the world
the real world right um there's gonna be
a lot of distractions
you know there's gonna be distance
there's gonna be friends family work
all these other different things that
are happening and not to mention
everything else that's happening in the
world right now and so
i think the best thing and we have
talked about this thing that we can do
is really take things day by day
without a pressure to put labels on
things without pressure to
you know go faster than we feel that we
should or feel that we need to
um and just experience life and chase
moments
that was a big theme that we had in the
villa was just chasing moments whether
that's
sleeping out on the day bed or eating
grilled cheesy
together it's just having a good time so
definitely looking forward to a lot more
of those moments
if i if i was saying like the the what
are we like what would you guys say that
you are
talking yeah definitely
we're absolutely talking we're seeing
each other if that's like